[Music]
[Music]
that's adele singing her heart out at
the 2022 brit awards
[Music]
seated atop a piano the songstress
performed i drink wine a track from her
latest album 30.
[Music]
at the end adele could feel the love in
london's o2 arena
out of adele's four nominations she
walked away with three wins
[Music]
was still a child
she took home trophies for song of the
year for easy on me artist of the year
and album of the year which she
dedicated to someone special i'm very
proud of myself for sticking to my guns
and putting out an album that was about
something so personal to me
because not many people do stuff like
that anymore obviously i thank everyone
i work with like the labels and stuff
but i'd like to dedicate this award to
my son
and get this 10 lasso stars hannah
waddingham and brett goldstein became
adele's unlikely heroes of the night
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
leading up to the ceremony the
powerhouse singer turned all the heads
on the red carpet so i'm very very
humbled
it was an armani kind of night for the
singer donning a black v-neck dress with
a sheer neckline accessorized with
dangly earrings she even made time for a
few selfies but needless to say this
sparkler on adele's left ring finger is
drawing a lot of attention with many
speculating she could be engaged to her
boyfriend rich paul e.t has reached out
to the couple for comment
the pair who went instagram official in
september have kept a pretty low profile
fast forward to january and the singer
unexpectedly postponed her las vegas
residency show the day before it was
supposed to start i'm so upset and i'm
really embarrassed and rumors started
swirling that adele's personal life may
have had something to do with it
but this is adele we're talking about
and she always finds a cheeky way to
address what's going on i'm a control
freak check out the pics she posted on
instagram last week to reveal her
performance at the brit awards in the
caption she subtly addressed speculation
that her relationship was on the rocks
simply writing oh and rich sends his
love
[Music]
you